here's my graph of cod
now you face the same problem of having
to restrict it in some way
the question is what would be the most
useful way unfortunately the most useful
way
ends up with a somewhat confusing result
because you might start off in exactly
the same way and say i want acute values
acute values make sense okay so you pick
these guys
there's multiplier two acute values okay
but now you certainly cannot do what you
did with sine
right because if you were to go the
other way
you're including a turning point there
right you're including a
portion of the graph that is not one to
one namely that portion okay
so we're busted we can't go from
negative planet two to pi on two like we
did the same
instead you have to go forward
so you get this domain not to pi okay
now this is interesting
not to pi believe it or not
this accounts were one of the most
irritating problems you've been dealing
with over the last
two and a half years namely when i give
you some measurements for a triangle
okay for instance suppose i say to you
so i just have to think
of a good example
if i gave you some measurements on this
thing okay and said maybe oh i don't
know
this is 32 degrees and this is
um let's call that
45 meters and
let's see let's make this what does it
look like
61 meters or something like that and i
said to me
can you tell me what this angle is can
you tell me what the angle is
okay now have a look at the information
that i've given to you what will be your
first reflex for how you would find
theta
you'd use the sine rule because the
information that you've got matches up
to
a on sine a b
on side b okay now when you put all this
information
in right you end up with a problem
because you'll end up with in this case
sine theta equals
some stuff okay and then you get your
calculator out and you say
theta equals and you say sine inverse
okay now you'll get some angle out here
but then there's a problem what's the
problem
the problem is you'll get some answer i
can guarantee you
you'll get an acute answer right because
think about this if i used
sine inverse sine inverse can only
possibly give me acute angles
because that's the way that i restricted
it right
admittedly it can give me negative acute
angles but i'm not going to give it a
negative ratio because of the way these
sides relate to each other
so it'll give me something a q
okay but of course you know that theta
might not be a q
right and we give a name to this problem
what's the what's the problem called
the fact that it could be something or
it could be something else what's the
other thing it could be
it could be um 180 pi minus that acute
angle it could be the obtuse version
of the same angle we call this the
ambiguous case right
now having a look at this you can
actually tell what the angle will be
because you can know
the ratios of the sides you can add them
all up and so on okay
but this ambiguous case business right
it comes directly from here okay the
sine rule has an ambiguous case because
we made it have an ambiguous case
now when you're using the cosine rule
there is no such problem can you see why
not
can you see what's going on when we use
when we define
cos inverse right because we can define
it from 0 to pi
it includes acute and obtuse angle so
you use the cosine rule
and you never get it wrong there's no
ambiguous case for the cosine rule
does this make sense right it's because
the angles that the cosine
inverse function can give you go all the
way from naught to pi
whereas stein's sinus is kind of stuck
he's like well i give you what i can
give you
it's only stuck in there okay
so that's what uh cosine inverse is
going to be restricted to
so what's it going to look like now
because its domain is all positive
therefore the range of cos inverse will
be
or positive right so very quickly it'll
look like this
okay now let's think back for me
let me go back 11 years when i was
learning invest trick for the first time
okay
and i was trying to graph these
functions i got these these
sine inverse and cos inverse
i got them massively confused because
there's so many different variants on
how you can draw this for instance
you can draw this or you can draw
this or you can draw this
or you can draw this okay and the longer
you stare at the more confusing it gets
okay so here's the way that i think
about it
sign right the portion that we've chosen
is it increasing or decreasing
it's going from negative one to one it's
increasing right therefore when you
reflect it
it's still increasing still increasing
okay
so that's how i remember this this one
that's sine inverse it must be
increasing okay
in exactly the same way what portion of
cos have we chosen to restrict
we've chosen a decreasing part right so
when you reflect it
it's still decreasing right so
sine is increasing so is sine inverse
close is decreasing so it's cause
inverse that's a helpful cue for you to
remember it
okay